paris der 31 august 1997 355 prinzessin
geborene diana frances spencer stirbt an
den folgen eines autounfalls
sie war nicht bei bewusstsein ihr kopf
lag auf ihrer brust auf ich habe ihren
kopf gehoben und die eine atemmaske
aufgelegt die ich immer im auto
mitführen
das hat ihr wieder bewusstsein gegeben
bis zur ankunft der rettung aber sie hat
nicht gesprochen keine worte gesagt die
ich hätte verstehen können
natürlich aber konnten wir davon das
ultimative foto zu bekommen auf dem sie
zusammen in ein schmuckgeschäft ging um
einen ring zu kaufen
[Musik]
die nachricht über dianas tod schockiert
die welt
[Musik]